i have a nine-year-old daughter i have
three kids and
i told my nine-year-old daughter that i
was going to be speaking with you and i
said what do you think about
the climate change climate change and
she said
the earth is on fire and we're all going
to die soon
and i asked her how that made her feel
and she said it made her feel
angry now you'd think that congresswoman
katie porter
would want to calm not stoke her
daughter's fears
but you'd be wrong now if democrats on
the left are willing to project their
own freaky phobias and radicalism on
their own kids
imagine what they're going to do to your
kids
they're just condemning the next
generation and beyond to becoming
woke like little susie will say my
pronouns are he
she him her i'm non-binary but
considering trinary
and by the way if you don't affirm her
insanity you're just gonna be canceled
as a person
the kids are going to become paranoid
they'll actually believe the world
is going to end in about 10 years what
i'm here to say is that
unlike you my generation will not give
up without the fight
and to be honest i don't believe for a
second
that you will actually do this they're
going to be terrified they'll be easier
to control though since they're going to
live in this
constant state of fear about everything
from a maga hat guy
to i don't know a police officer in a
uniform
the kids will be hypochondriacs they're
going to treat dr anthony fauci
as the last word on all things health
and happiness related
mommy i have the sniffles oh mommy what
about the variants
should americans be ready for a new
surge in cases
in the next couple of months dr fauci
well i think you always want to be
prepared for that type of thing
there may be variants that are
circulating well
the kids are going to be disrespectful
because they're going to hate the
country
and in a way i think they're going to
hate you for having all your old
bourgeois values
meanwhile they'll be taught to worship
marx as agitators as
courageous climate revolutionaries
but it doesn't have to be this way that
was manure by the way
that was their protest parents need to
step up
and start teaching kids actual history
real science
and real critical thinking skills we can
do our part
to stop all this madness you don't want
your kids collecting manure and throwing
it in the street do you
of course when it comes to being woke or
anti-racist
democrats are the planet's biggest
hypocrites though
case in point every single senate dem
just voted against cutting off taxpayer
funding
to colleges that discriminate against
asian americans so when it comes to real
racial discrimination democrats aren't
just
absent they actively defend it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else